welcome to this video plane Kampai this
is Venezuela near columbia at the french
being answered by the exchange variation
ja h 3 that's very ambitious play okay
but what can you do the exchange
variation is some it's a viable option
against the French need to try to come
on already I got something under
something on c2 okay but he covered it
let's let's see maybe I can can even
exchange such as a Second Age 3 would be
would be funny but if I take on h3 is
this completely ridiculous now it's it's
almost ridiculous but come on let's do
that he lost quite some time and I've
got nite nite g6 and night eh for stuff
coming yeah no it's not it's not
completely completely ridiculous and
let's see oh this is the sir this I
didn't really appreciate and that's a
problem
hmm that's embarrassing without this
bishop it's it's tricky okay but if it
takes that at least I need to look I
need to look lift its maybe maybe this
is maybe this is at least playable I
didn't intend any of that of course what
ok maybe at this it is disabled
okay okay I thought you should at least
wait until I play a six or something
while rook g6 I mean this is dangerous
check without any doubt night f5 neither
five simply or not yeah yeah I snow he
has got no way to attack the Queen
actually and this has multiple threats
even 93 and it's a threat or root G 393
mm and taking ELQ a black wins here he
shouldn't take on d6 really i think you
cannot afford that yeah what has no move
here I just take g3 next and win it yeah
so much for the exchange variation but
ok Bishop a tree was wasn't I wasn't
correct probably
okay let's let's consider Nigeria is the
easiest job when with a no is there some
way for him to I mean things i also have
93 here this is why i'm thinking just
for a moment 93 Bishop g4 maybe
I can take f1 and win but maybe 93 is
even easier if it takes with the f porn
queen g3 queen g2 is made and I'm
threatening made on g2 it's probably
just winning the Queen isn't it yeah
it's probably easier maybe I'm
overlooking something with 93 but I
thought night g3 Bishop g4 at least it's
not an immediate kill it's Luke g3 okay
I'll just take it white resides yeah I
mean probably it isn't an act and
released scene i'd be five yeah okay
well might be five at least as a draw i
mean i can't play night chief Queen g4
check and but yeah okay this is there is
some danger and this is not it's not
completely idiotic if he let's say plays
a developing news like this and there is
this coming until black wins even I'm
not sure maybe this this is a probably
right the question is what here is there
something else yeah actually I always
have Queen g4 check and clean edge we
check this is perpetual this is quite
difficult to avoid am really I wasn't
sure what he should play but 96 I think
it's just losing no it isn't interesting
Queen d3 is then the computer defense
interesting intending rook g6 check 95
yeah but now the evaluation goes down
for white
looks extremely fishy really can't to
allow all that okay night here and I bet
that's a completely unhuman way to play
anyway but still queen age six to play
f6 young all rook takes g5 I mean even
that would be quite nice and then the
computer gives you three as being
slightly better for black really I don't
understand any of that but what is the
say I've got to cram I'm piece down
right i mean i can i can check if
everything else fails i can just play
this year and black is just better
computer likes white slightly which is I
think quite strange I've got two points
for the exchange and a compact position
the nights are nice iam yeah okay it's
it just a strange evaluation as also ff6
yeah and what's the computer doing
against that King g2 oh wow computer
chess at its best FG is g5 rook h1
strange stuff okay but that's very
difficult to do to defend yeah and this
is just just the win I was I saw that
and I thought okay it's winning but yeah
I could have done that as well but 93 is
also pretty pretty good with the maid on
G to enter the Queen attacked okay
thanks for watching